breaking news breaking news breaking
news the mayor of miami just announced
that he is going to take 100
of his next paycheck in bitcoin just a
few minutes ago i tweeted i said it is
time who is going to be the first
american politician to accept their
salary in bitcoin and of course this is
like a layup of layups for the man that
met the legend francis suarez of miami
he said i'm going to take my next
paycheck 100 in bitcoin problem solved
and then he tagged the cio of miami said
can you help who by the way the cio of
miami mike swarovski already is taking a
portion of his salary in bitcoin as well
but now we have the mayor of miami going
all in committing to take 100
of his next paycheck in bitcoin this has
massive ramifications in my opinion
first we now have a sitting u.s
politician who has some level of
national notoriety who has committed to
take a portion in this case 100 of his
paycheck in bitcoin
yes it is a local politician yes it is
the mayor of one of the major cities in
the country but it does not matter for
the first time in history we now have a
sitting u.s politician that is going to
take their salary
in bitcoin
the way that they are going to do it
according to the tweets is they are
going to use strike the same exact
service that is going ahead and helping
some of the major
professional athletes like russ ocon and
others saquon barkley and others they
now are helping mike saurosti at
miami the cio take part of his salary in
bitcoin and now you have the mayor the
sitting elected official taking 100 of
his next paycheck in bitcoin the reason
why this is important is because once
you get one
then you'll get two and once you get two
then you get them all and just like we
saw in the public companies on in
corporate balance sheets once
microstrategy did it then square did it
and tesla did it and then the miners did
it and then more and more and more
companies will do it that is what we're
about to watch is we just saw the very
first u.s sitting politician commit to
doing this do not be surprised if we see
more politicians agreeing to do this
will ted cruz do it will senator lumbus
do it will congressman warren davidson
do it how many more politicians by the
end of the year
i'm going to go ask all of them can we
get them to commit to take a portion of
it
that is how you start to create momentum
and so when you guys see the mayor doing
it one are we surprised that he's the
one doing it and two a hundred percent
is very different than five ten twenty
percent of it yeah i'm not surprised uh
i think
it sounds like he's going to be doing
you know the next paycheck not 100 of
his salary uh which is still good i
think it comes back to everything that i
mentioned before which is if you're
buying this asset and you're investing
in bitcoin with a portion of your
paycheck or or a portion of your annual
salaries anyways why wouldn't you do
this right bitcoin is good for business
it's good for government officials
there's a strong strong strong community
that comes with uh that endorsement that
you believe in the asset and i think
it's no brainer for for someone to do
this and it only makes sense like
someone uh like mayor schwarz who has
been leading the train when it comes to
uh innovation and acceptance of crypto
here in america uh that he does at first
john what do you think would you see
this
mayor has continuously been a ford
thinker um he has brought miami i think
to the forefront of crypto in the united
states this is another example of it i
think the dominoes will fall he will do
it uh other people will not only get
publicity and look into the asset and go
into cryptocurrency and bitcoin in
specific um but other senators and
congressmen and um all other politicians
will do it as well
look pay me in bitcoin another guy
getting paid in bitcoin
are we all gonna take 100
of our salaries in bitcoin every chance
i every chance i get i get paid in
bitcoin
every single one
that's possible
well now you can take every single
paycheck with strike true i'm not going
to turn this into a strike ad but
definitely i'm talking you know you work
with an advertiser it's like hey let's
get this deal done here we're not going
to get time to set up strike
but yeah every chance is possible for
sure the part that i really enjoy about
uh watching this is we are now seeing
politicians get ushered into the digital
age and the speed on the internet
happens so quickly i tweeted that he
just quote tweeted it look here here we
go right here strike already saying that
they already are getting them set up on
strike on it step one strike dot me
slash download step two done
absolutely legends over there uh but the
the part that you're watching is like as
they just quickly respond he didn't talk
to anyone he didn't go ask a campaign
manager he didn't talk to his chief of
staff he didn't call up somebody and ask
for permission he literally said i want
to do this the technology is available
bam done and guess what i promise you
we'll come back here tomorrow and every
single major news outlet in the country
is going to be writing about the mayor
of miami taking a portion of his salary
in bitcoin and that's again remember
what i said every politician they know
the game you gotta stay in the news the
beauty of this is this is good for the
politicians this is good for the people
and it aligns incentives because guess
what there's a ton of people who never
ever ever cared about miami knew who
this guy was or
would ever even think about helping him
but now he's a bitcoin
now he's got an entire generation of
people he's got millions of people
around the world that all want to see
him be successful and that's what
bitcoin can do bitcoin is good for
business